it starts with a simple cough and before
you know it millions of people are
infected and it won't stop there it
could keep growing and growing until
billions of people are sick flights are
canceled
cities are quarantined and hospitals are
flooded with patients this is what's
known as a global pandemic could we
experience something like this how would
a pandemic affect civilization how does
something like this happen and how could
you avoid it this is what if and here's
what would happen if we had a worldwide
pandemic a worldwide pandemic like this
wouldn't be new to the human race it
happened in 1918 and was known as the
Spanish flu it infected about 1/3 of the
global population and killed an
estimated 50 million people
so before we start completely freaking
out about the end of the world you can
take a bit of comfort in knowing this
most likely doesn't mean the end of
civilization but that doesn't mean there
won't be consequences before we get to
what might happen how does a pandemic
start anyway well widely spread
epidemics in the past like the Spanish
flu as well as SARS in 2003 began with a
strain of influenza or the flu now there
are two main types of influenza type A
which typically comes from animals
including Birds cats pigs and horses and
type B viruses which are only common
among humans the symptoms of a virus
like this are things we've all
experienced runny nose fever headache
and just general cold symptoms but in
other cases influenza can also result in
respiratory issues
any failure or even death but keep in
mind those aren't guaranteed to happen a
disease like this could infect over two
and a half billion people why so many
well the main thing about these
influenza strains is that they can be
carried through the air if someone has
it and breathes in your direction you
could breathe in microscopic water
droplets carrying the virus or if you
touch a surface that has the virus on it
and then touch your face you could also
catch the disease you might not even
feel the symptoms of influenza right
away it could take a few hours or even
up to two weeks this means you could be
interacting with people as usual and
unknowingly be infecting them and today
the world is a lot different than it was
during 1918 Spanish flu in addition to
the world's population being much higher
we also live very differently cities are
more dense with places like Mumbai
having over 76,000 people per square
mile with people living closer together
it means we can infect each other more
easily not only that but we travel the
world with ease now people who
unknowingly carry a virus can quickly
bring it to the other side of the world
if this new virus were to spread to just
a single person who spread it to another
single person and another and another as
time went on it would eventually infect
millions as people got infected planes
would be grounded and entire countries
could be quarantined if it got bad
enough we might not even be able to
leave our homes due to the risk of
infecting people or getting infected
ourselves getting help at a hospital
could be difficult too with billions of
people infected it's unlikely hospitals
would be able to care for everyone if
we're dealing with a pandemic that
spreads the same way as the Spanish flu
did we could anticipate anywhere between
200 to 425 million deaths and that's out
of the approximately two and a half
billion people who would be in
did but how likely is it that a scenario
like this will happen well it's hard to
say experts say that humanity is due for
a massive pandemic it happened 100 years
ago with the Spanish flu and before that
with the bubonic plague in 1347
unfortunately pandemics like these are
just a reality of human civilization but
that doesn't mean a pandemic today would
be as bad as the Spanish flu although
the disease might spread more
efficiently than ever before it also
might be easier than ever to cure it
although a pandemic implies that you'll
have little immunity to it doctors could
develop a vaccine for it today
with increased technology and
communication being more seamless than
ever the world's scientists could work
together you could have doctors in New
York talking with researchers in China
trying to solve a pandemic it definitely
wouldn't be easy and could take up to a
year but eventually a vaccine could be
invented the next issue would be how it
gets distributed if countries aren't
willing to work together and distribute
the vaccines fairly it could cause some
serious conflict but assuming they all
do work together it could eventually
stop the pandemic hopefully something
like this won't happen in the first
place
after all we're now better at monitoring
animals and their diseases than ever
before and by knowing the consequences
of a real pandemic hopefully we can stop
the spread of infections before they go
any further so how can you avoid
something like this
well according to health experts the
rules are pretty simple similar to
avoiding the common cold you should wash
your hands a lot and keep away from
people coughing and sneezing and if
you're feeling sick you should
definitely see a doctor right away
also would you please cough or sneeze
into a tissue or an elbow so although
everybody doesn't have to die in this
scenario it would have a severe impact
on people and if the world isn't willing
to work and cooperate together the
realities of a new pandemic could be
pretty grim
want to know something that isn't so
grim
how about traveling to Mars well we'll
leave that story for another what-if
[Music]
you